que maxime sous-estiment c'est la
désaffection des gens à l'encontre de
danse avec les stars
on sait on l'a dit ici c'est scénarisé
ils les stars maintenant les quelques
stars qui avait son parti ça n'arrive
rien à dire il faut tout rires
souveraineté c'est pas une star c'est
elle et elle est promue dans une erreur
qui va en faire une animatrice donc il
ya pas de suspense il n'y a pas
d'appétence par exemple je n'en ai
jamais raté un demain je vais pas
regarder danse avec les stars
je regarderai en replay ya plus
d'intérêt alors non pas du genre de vous
savez qui dansent à 3 c'est un autre
exercice et un trio des trois c'est un
trio effectivement et donc on va
s'intéresser avant d'invoquer maertens
parmi les blessés visiblement n'en est
rien non non non il il a un bon vous
savez avec qui il va donc c'est avec
shy'm évidemment alors j'ai envie de
dire et alors je voulais dire oui parce
que c'est des rumeurs is in china
princesse maxima l'automotrice a fait ça
fait un beau trio pour le co et ouais ça
fait c'est pas lui jeter occasions de
jeu les petits la semaine dernière vous
vous souvenez vous c'était pas mal je
vous ai pas lues et le gagnant shaima
leurs mains à l'aide et avec le fils de
si mes infos sont d'équipé ce qu'elle
dit je crois je crois que je crois qu'il
ya un magazine qui sort avec ça a lâché
je connais quelques images de ceux de
votre beauté rennes ce qu'elle est
l'amie rami de ludivine regarder
[Musique]
il est temps de découvrir les résultats
de vos votes qui avez vous décidé de
sauver ce soir bravo à teyran
c'est manifester pour vous continuer la
compétition existe elle est avec nous la
semaine prochaine on en a déjà parlé
on va pas demander si ces photos qui
étaient qualifie plutôt que thérèse en
tous les cas ça avant dans la
compétition